i've never really viewed myself as
particularly talented where i excel
is
ridiculous
sickening work ethic you know while the
other guy's sleeping
i'm working while the other guy's eating
i'm working the only thing that i see
that
is
distinctly different about me is
i'm not afraid to die on a treadmill i
will run you would not be outworked i
will not be outworked right period yeah
you know
you might have more talent than me
you might be smarter than me you might
be sexier than me you might be all of
those things you got it on me in nine
categories but if we get on the
treadmill together there's two things
you're getting off first yeah or i'm
gonna die
it's really that simple right so you're
not going to outwork me when i do
something i want to win i want it to be
number one and i want to smash it the
first step
before anybody else in the world
believes it is you have to believe
nobody knows anything
if nobody knows
then i have to trust me
nobody knows what you are
like even sometimes you don't really
even know what you what you are you got
to take your shot
confucius
said
he who says he can
and he who says he can't are both
usually right grow or die was the basic
central premise that we were working
with that if you're not if you don't
grow you will perish we did we didn't
grow up uh with the sense that
where we were was where we were going to
be you know we grew up with the sense
that where we were almost didn't matter
because
we were becoming something greater when
i started i had you know all these grand
ambitions of what i wanted to be and
what i wanted to do and you know i want
to be the biggest movie star in the
world um so i studied that and i worked
out i got my body crazy and i did you
know just got my head around um doing
everything i could do to be the biggest
movie star in the world you know and
then i had a taste of that
i know for a fact that
i'm stronger than i thought i was make a
choice like you just decide
what it's going to be who you're going
to be how you're going to do it just
decide
your life your happiness is your
responsibility
and your responsibility alone
the separation of talent and skill is
one of the greatest misunderstood
concepts for people who are trying to
excel who have dreams that want to do
things talent you have naturally skill
is only developed by hours and hours and
hours of beating on your craft in terms
of setting goals i was like i want to be
the biggest movie star in the world
when i moved into acting that was the
first time i started applying
skill to
my talents right and you know i was look
i look at skill and talent separately
like p you're born with talent you know
it's like there's certain things that
you just do naturally you were gifted
with a talent and you have it um but
skill is acquired through discipline and
you know i've never seen myself as
particularly talented where i excel is
i'm willing to die in the process of
acquiring skill
99
of people are not willing to do what it
takes to make their dreams come true the
marines have a saying everybody wants to
go to heaven but nobody wants to die and
that's just real at the center of
bringing any dream into fruition is
self-discipline you know some something
as simple as food and eating is not
about your body as much as it is about
your mind it's getting command of your
mind to be able to choose actions that
are in your own best interest every day
we are choosing [ __ ] that's not in our
own best interest right so if the world
is attacking you and the world wants to
fight you and the world's trying to hold
you down so you're going to kick
yourself in the balls so you don't stop
yourself from getting what you dream
self-discipline is the center of all
material success you cannot win the war
against the world
if you can't win the war against your
own mind i believe that self-discipline
is
the definition of self-love
that when you say that you love yourself
that means that you have behavior
towards yourself
that is loving it's like you say to
yourself hey man look
i know you got a a test on monday you
know and i know you really want to go
out with your friends and saturday night
you want to go out but if you fail that
test you're not going to feel good about
yourself you know i just i love you too
much to let you go out tonight
self-discipline is
self-love if you want to be happy you
have to love yourself which means you
have to discipline your behavior the
road to
sustained happiness is through
disciplining your behavior and i think
the word discipline has kind of gotten
a bad name we think about it in terms of
punishment i'm not talking about
discipline in that way i'm talking about
discipline
in the sense that you you forego
immediate
pleasure
for the exchange of long-term
self-respect
if you set your priorities you start at
the top
and every day you start at your first
priority and you work your way down and
when it's time to go to sleep you go to
sleep and you don't worry about whatever
you missed and you wake up the next day
and start at the top of your priorities
again and you just keep going until
you don't have energy and that that to
me that works very well and i just have
to make sure that i keep my priorities
in order because you don't want to
uh slip and be dealing with number eight
on your priority list and you haven't
dealt with number three yet
i believe
and i learned very young from a parent
that you don't try to build a wall you
don't set out to build a wall you don't
say i'm going to build the biggest
baddest greatest wall that's ever been
built you don't start there you say i'm
going to lay this brick as perfectly as
a brick can be laid there will not be
one brick on the face of the earth
that's going to be laid better than this
brick that i'm going to lay in this next
10 minutes
and you do that every single day and
soon and soon you have a wall and i
think psychologically the advantage that
that gives me over a lot of people that
i
have been in competition with in
different situations is it's difficult
to take the first step when you look how
big the task is the task is never huge
to me it's always
one brick
i think that the important thing is
there there's there's one relationship
that you have to maintain and that's the
one with you right and it's like if if
you're not loving you if you're not
taking care of you everything and
everybody is second to you taking care
of you everybody has dreams
and and as much as you you you want to
be able to listen a little bit because
somebody's going to give you a gem but
you nobody knows but you you can't get
advice on what you should do with your
life
right nobody knows what you are
like even sometimes you don't really
even know what you what you are you got
to take your shot and
it's like as much as you want people to
agree and you want the people around you
to be supporting your dreams and all
it's not going to be like that all the
time you got to do it alone and people
will help you and when you when you get
the ball rolling people will jump on but
if you don't believe nobody else is
going to believe people come along
because your belief is so insane
you can't wait for somebody to think you
can do it and it's like following your
dreams
is a lonely solitary scary dangerous
pursuit and you got to be willing to
risk everything to become that seed of
what you believe
taking responsibility accepting
responsibility is not an admission of
guilt like you're not you're not
admitting at fault taking responsibility
is a recognition of the power that you
seize when you stop blaming people it's
not like you're letting somebody who
wronged you off the hook like taking
responsibility is an act of emotional
self-defense taking responsibility is
taking your power back
your life your happiness is your
responsibility and your responsibility
alone
i think that there's a certain
delusional quality that all successful
people have to have you have to believe
that something different than what has
happened for the last
50 million years of history you have to
believe that something different can
happen
i realized that when to have the level
of success that i want to have it's
difficult to spread it out and do
multiple things you know it's in order
to
to be world class and i've made a
decision i want to be
world class and it just it takes such a
desperate obsessive focus to to excel on
a certain on the level that that i want
to make movies there's a concept that i
don't want to be
uh
an icon i want to be an idea you know i
want to represent an idea i want to
represent possibilities i want to
represent
magic right that you're in a universe
and two plus two equals four
two plus two only equals four if you
accept that two plus two equals four two
plus two two's gonna be what i wanted to
be you know and there's a a redemptive
power that making a choice has
you know rather than feeling like your
effect to all the things that are
happening make a choice right you just
decide
what it's going to be who you're going
to be how you're going to do it just
decide and then from that point the
universe is going to get out your way
it's like it's water it wants to it
wants to move and go around stuff you
know so for for me i want to represent
possibilities i want to represent the
idea that
you really can make what you want one of
my favorite books is the alchemist
paolo coelho and i just believe that i
can create whatever i want to create if
i can put my head on it right study it
learn the patterns and i feel very
strongly that we are who we choose to be
you